I want to hear your story Rose I knew I  would wait for him from ever going away  for a while  I hope here will they get by where's  your sympathies like with us all with  the break  need to be capital you fertilize with  the only time around you're a woman look  directly into a man's eyes when she is  explained  you come out to me right there well I  might if you had some manner  oh you have over men like that so much  because education just because of you  crows CAW yeah  [Music]  tell me where he is if you come to take  me out  [Music]  I think about  analysis new people starting seems true  I committed my memories to the book of  world my secret culture  honey she'll make some one to Ackley so  what did I tell you do not look right in  the eye until Russia to historians which  to believe only see you see with love is  the truth  you  [Music]